let's rejoin the conversation for part
three
of my interview with dr joseph urban
so let me also uh maybe move to a
slightly different topic because one of
the things that fascinates me about this
work
is not only that it requires some
different technologies but those
different technologies you know machine
learning mathematics
pure pure mathematics and
then also fear improving have been quite
distinct communities i mean
there are overlaps of course especially
in individuals like yourself but largely
these are
areas where i say there hasn't been a
lot of cross-fertilization
and yet to make your project a success
you had to find people that had aptitude
and interest
in at least some combination of these
areas can you tell me a little bit about
the
the human challenge of bringing together
a project of this size and scope and
multi-disciplinary nature
yeah it's it's really a good question
so it's it's amazing how
how mistrustful
and distant is the
sort of statistical machine learning
community and the
what's a logic community i i would say
the people who do logic they
they have really a lot of trouble
uh understanding how statistical machine
learning works like
if you are a logician when they taught
you
the first course in some proving
you you get you you are trained
like hell in in this sort of counter
example
based reasoning so somebody gives you a
proof
and you find a counter example so so you
you always do this like
you you are trained as a mathematician
to to always come up with counter
examples
so so for for a mathematician
logician reasoning person
as soon as something is only working
statistically
and they can come up with counter
examples like
you see some simple machine learner
which only uses some
symbolic features of some formula you
immediately come up with a counter
example why
why this algorithm will fail on on a
particular problem right
and they they sort of do not very often
they do not get
the big picture right like that we are
starting somewhere and
instead of like manually crafting uh
some simple heuristics we are sort of
trying to gradually learn more and more
complicated heuristics
in some frameworks that
we that might well typically always have
some theoretical limits but but it's
quite hard to figure out what are
the theoretical limits like how ex
how strong are the machine learning
frameworks for example
so it's really hard for the logic people
to
to trust statistical machine learning
and it's it's the same for the
statistical machine learning people
they have a lot of problem understanding
logic like that that's not what they do
like some crazy axioms and
whatever like give me my corpus and
we'll do some training and testing on
that
that's what the statistical machining
people do
um so the this is really
an interesting issue how
how hard it is to to get somebody
on board and start combining
both both of these things in in my
group it worked in
in various ways so obviously i am
sort of the the rationalizer here who
tries to explain to people like
why we need to do things with logic how
cool it is to do deduction that you can
generate a lot of data by running
automated theorem previous
that it's much better than just some
stupid
natural language processing when
somebody gives you the brown corpus and
that's it you cannot do any inference on
that etc etc
uh and to to to to the logicians
like why we need the the machine
learning
and what is the big picture like even
though
we might be using some very stupid
machine learning right now
we we have ways to go forward like there
are more and more complicated machine
learning methods
and it's sort of up to them to come up
with for example intelligent features
uh that they are using themselves when
they are
so one day how you can catch them is to
tell them so so how did you prove this
right like how did you do some
exhaustive algorithm
no you you haven't you have been trained
uh and your brain has been trained
so so try to try to figure out try to
ask yourself like
what was the algorithm you are using for
doing doing the theorem and like
except for me or like there are the
the method is also to let these people
talk together right like so you hire
one guy who is doing machine learning
another guy who is doing theorem proving
and now you sort of force force them to
communicate
to to be at the same progress meetings
etc
but it's not trivial so for example
some five years ago i went to visit
google
and they started a project basically in
in my area and i
i got the same feedback from from the
leader there from
christian seger who also like he hired
very good theory proving people for
example by he was saying
you know these people they don't buy
into machine learning
and it's it's sort of a universal
problem but
i think it's improving like people are
seeing the light business
yeah it's true i mean interdisciplinary
work in any given set of scientific
disciplines
uh does seem to be a bit rare you know
in this area
i think it's really fascinating because
the history
of science and mathematics is full of
quotes from famous scientists like
einstein of course being the
the the most quotable who has all sorts
of examples where he said you know the
the the idea about this uh
mathematical achievement just came to me
in a sort of flash of inspiration
intuition and so it's this interplay
between
a sort of intuitive statistical pattern
matching approach that says ah this this
just has to be true it just
fits it feels right and then the
the deliberative process of mathematics
that goes about
explaining you know why that intuition
is right because even if you're einstein
you can't stand up at a
scientific conference and said i say i
just know it to be true
right that's not good enough you have to
say i believed passionately that this
was true because it came to me while i
was playing violin
but here let me show you the now the
detailed proof in so many steps that
proves on him irrefutably that in fact
this must be true
so uh when when people are maybe
resistant to these two modes
i'm surprised that that they don't kind
of look back about the history of
science and see that
clearly must be at least in some way the
process of doing science having these
two different modes of thinking
it's it's it's it's a good good point
like i think
einstein is really a great example
because he came up with something
so counter-intuitive like relativity
and he
he sort of forces you
to accept the solution the theory
by doing these beautiful thought thought
experiments
uh and you you sort of
he's sort of using deduction
to force you to to accept the new
intuition uh so you you can sort of see
see the feedback loop there right like
he he
he has a heart problem he comes up with
a crazy solution by
by whatever crazy enlightenment method
and and he he very deductively
justifies that and people
now basically go through that process
when they
learn physics and they sort of accept it
and the physicists really start to think
with these intuitions right so it
becomes
some part of uh system one or system two
or uh
whatever it is the sort of terminology
for for this
and uh in general you are also right
that
in in mathematics this has been an
ongoing
battle between differently oriented
people
so they're they're always where people
who who wouldn't give up mathematical
intuition
for any formalization automation at etc
and who would
like penrose right like who would
actively deny
and come up with complicated theories
why machines will never be as good
in theorem proving as humans
but it's probably because they haven't
had these two modes i was just also
there's a famous indian mathematician
from quite long
ago that that i thought he was also uh
quite well known for for coming up on
all sorts of things
what was his name do you recall yeah
right yeah
you would he would and i think his he
had some phenomenal output where he
would
he would write down these theorems
without the proofs a lot of them would
be
wrong but a lot of them would later turn
out to be right and they had just sort
of come to him in a dream or something
oh yeah yeah it's it's it's a
a is a counter example to to a lot of
things like his intuitions
were so extremely good and the thought
process or
whatever you call it intuition process
is
he he was doing it's probably quite
unexplored and uh
people probably don't know much about
how
how he how he was getting getting these
results but but it
it's very other people too i like
einstein punk
like everybody could get these sort of
flashes of intuition that you
that you mentioned yeah i mean i don't
think that he's really a
a counter example i mean to me at least
he's trying
i'm trying to make the point that this
is this is actually common even amongst
mathematicians that we think of as being
so
incredibly step-by-step and formal and
rational this
this intuitive approach is ubiquitous
and yeah it's it's not confined to
the the historical geniuses like
einstein
um but it's even some uh these different
modes of thought
uh happen all the time just to to
regular people about
you know you realize something must be
true and then
your conscious mind uh does some theorem
proving right it tries to say
what are the reasons why i should
believe that yeah
it came to me in a flash so so this just
seems to be a
natural part of human intelligence and
you've done a brilliant thing by
by doing a very large-scale concrete
project to try to bring these two modes
of thought to bear
on some very uh practical and hard
scientific problems
yeah we try just one quick comment i
i read recently this might be a very
common knowledge today
that humans are really good
at uh like fake um
justifications so there are various
experiments with the left and right
hemisphere
when when somehow if you if you make
like one of the hemispheres believes
something
it's it's very good at rationalizing it
by by basically making up
making up some justification so the
the two processes like the the one when
you
have the intuition that something is
true and the one
when you rationalize it are probably
pretty different processes even in
humans
yeah there's good there's really uh so
i've advertised kind of on this channel
before
daniel kahneman's work thinking fast and
flow fast and slow which is really
very accessible and details a lot of the
psychological experiments like
that you're talking about that yeah
people people do have the flash of
inspiration
sort of the bad version of this is is
that they rationalize what they
already know by inventing some truth
inventing an argument as opposed to
using the argument as a way to debug the
inspiration
yeah we'll pause the conversation here
and return in my next video
for part four the final segment of my
interview with dr joseph urban